PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN STRUGGLING
THIS WINTER.
>> NEW YORK GOVERNOR ANDREW
CUOMO AND DEFENSE AS BIPARTISAN
BACKLASH MOUNTS OVER HIS
HANDLING OF COVID-19 NURSING
HOME DEATHS.
>> I WANT TO SET THE RECORD
STRAIGHT ON NURSING HOMES, WE
CREATED A VOID BY NOT PRODUCING
ENOUGH PUBLIC INFORMATION FAST
ENOUGH.
THEN IT WAS EXPLOITED WITH
MISINFORMATION, PEOPLE PLAYING
POLITICS, REPUBLICANS PLAYING
POLITICS, PERSONAL ATTACKS,
PERSONAL AGENDAS.
>> REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS IN THE
STATE ARE MOVING TO FORM
IMPEACHMENT COMMISSION TO FIND
OUT WHAT REALLY HAPPENED.
HERE TO REACT, NEW YORK AS A
REPUBLICAN CONFEDERATE LEADER
WILL BERKELEY.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW, THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US, YOU SEE THAT
DEFENSE BY CUOMO, THE LATEST OF
MANY.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF HIM SAYING
THERE WAS JUST A VOID OF
INFORMATION?
>> I FIND THAT AN IRONY.
WE HAVE BEEN TRYING TO GET THIS
INFORMATION FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH FOR MONTHS AND MONTHS
AND KEPT GETTING STONEWALLED AND
THAT DID RAISE SUSPICIONS, WHY
ARE WE GETTING STONEWALLED?
WAS IT BECAUSE IT WENT AGAINST
THE GOVERNOR’S STORY ABOUT
PROVIDING GREAT LEADERSHIP
DURING THIS PANDEMIC AND THE
BOMBSHELL REPORT BY THE
DEMOCRATIC ATTORNEY GENERAL IN
NEW YORK THAT SAID THE GOVERNOR
WAS UNDERREPORTING NURSING HOME
DEATHS BY AS MUCH AS 50% AND THE
CLOSED-DOOR MEETING, TOP A TO
THE GOVERNOR SAID WE FROZEN WE
DIDN’T PROVIDE THIS INFORMATION
BECAUSE WE WERE WORRIED ABOUT AS
PART OF JUSTICE INVESTIGATION
AND WE WERE WORRIED ABOUT THE
POLITICAL FALLOUT.
THERE SEEMS TO BE A LOT OF
EVIDENCE POINTING TO THE FACT
THAT THERE WAS SOME SORT OF
COVER-UP.
MYSELF AND MY COLLEAGUES FEEL
STRONGLY WE OUGHT TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT AND WE OWE IT TO
THOSE FAMILIES WHO LOST LOVED
ONES.
>> I WANT TO LOOK AT WHERE THE
COMMISSION MIGHT BE MOVING
FORWARD.
TO THE BEST OF YOUR KNOWLEDGE TO
INVESTIGATE WHAT HAPPENED, WHY
WOULD THIS BE BACK IN PLACE IN
TERMS OF NURSING HOMES?
>> GREAT QUESTION THAT REQUIRES
FURTHER INVESTIGATION.
THE GOVERNOR’S LINE IS WE ARE
WORRIED ABOUT MOVING PEOPLE OUT
OF THE HOSPITAL AND NURSING
HOMES.
TO ME IT SEEMS LOGICAL THAT WHEN
YOU SEND SOMEONE WHO HAS
COVID-19 INFECTION INTO A
NURSING HOME EVEN IF COVID-19 IS
ALREADY IN THE NURSING HOME IT
WILL INCREASE INFECTION RATES IN
NURSING HOMES.
INDEED THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
STUDIES SAYING BY DOING THAT
THEY CAUSED 1000 ADDITIONAL
DEATHS IN NURSING HOMES BUT THAT
NEEDS TO BE LOOKED AT.
WE CAN LOOK AT THAT IN THE
LEGISLATURE, WE OUGHT TO DO THAT
RIGHT AWAY AND YOU SUBPOENA
POWER AND GET THE COMMISSIONER
OF HEALTH TO TESTIFY UNDER OATH
AND FIND OUT WHAT HAPPENED AND
WE NEED TO DO THAT TO PREVENT
SOMETHING LIKE THIS HAPPENING
AGAIN.
THAT IS ONE ISSUE, THE IDEA OF A
COVER-UP, THAT DOESN’T HELP
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS OF THE
LEGISLATURE OR THE PUBLIC.
TODD: --
STEVE: IF REPUBLICANS ARE
CALLING FRENCH PATIENT COUNSEL
IS ONE THING, BUT IF IT IS
BIPARTISAN THAT IS ANOTHER
BALLGAME.
WE HAVE HEARD BASED ON WHAT WAS
RUN TO RUN KIM, ASSEMBLYMAN,
DEMOCRAT INTIMIDATION, THERE
MIGHT BE MORE INTEREST AMONG
DEMOCRATS, WITH THE POLITICAL
CLIMATE IN NEW YORK OF
DEMOCRATS, AND APPETITE TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT CUOMO ON THIS
ISSUE?
>> THEY STARTED MOVING AS FAST
AS I WOULD LIKE TO SEE BUT
THERE’S CRACKS IN THE POLITICAL
WALL OF TRYING TO PROTECT THE
FELLOW DEMOCRAT WHO HAPPENS TO
BE THE GOVERNOR.
BECAUSE OF REASONS LIKE HIM
BULLYING MEMBERS LIKE RON KIM,
HIS STAFF WAS OUT PUSHING THIS
NARRATIVE WITH LEGISLATORS, THAT
GETS PEOPLE’S BAGS UP AND THE
PUBLIC OUTCRY, PEOPLE LIKE
JANICE DEAN, TRYING TO BRING
LIGHT TO THIS ISSUE, THERE IS
POLITICAL PRESSURE.
SO IF YOU ASKED ME THAT? AGO I
WOULD HAVE SAID CHANCES WERE
UNLIKELY BUT THE WAY THINGS ARE
PROGRESSING I AM OPTIMISTIC AND
I HOPE THEY DON’T SEE THIS AS A
PARTISAN THING.
IT IS BIPARTISAN, THOSE PEOPLE
LOST IN NURSING HOMES WHAT
DEMOCRATS OR REPUBLICANS, THEY
WERE NEW YORKERS, THEY SERVE
ACCOUNTABILITY OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF THIS.
>> WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE.
IT IS BIPARTISAN AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO FOLLOW THIS AND SEE
WHERE THIS INVESTIGATION LEADS
HOPEFULLY TO ACCOUNTABILITY.
IMPORTANT TO NOTE WE REDID REACH
OF THE GOVERNOR CUOMO’S OFFICE,
HAVE NOT HEARD BACK AS OF YET